well no no no I got the wrong outfit I
need to be the monorail guy get let me
be the monorail there we go
I gotta be that guy because I am that
guy I'm that fly [ __ ] oh yeah yeah you
felt that this is very Jetson radio look
at this hello oh hello
Wow what is that ball come from what is
this game wait how do you how do you tap
a ball again uh you press B if you're
using it surely what what what happened
that was not something I should have
been doing what daddy damn it how do I
get hit like I don't understand yeah
yeah but it goes so fast like what am I
doing with my life man me and Ken MLG Oh
taste it in days sorry
don't don't quote me all night send it
to me in Swedish smoker mate oven right
what do you doing wait am i way what
does the other buttons do oh well yeah
it's pretty much just this is dodgeball
if you're on drugs and looks it with
alligator and robot he's dead you only
have one life left
you did yeah okay I died deal with it
but what is life gonna change for you
guys whoa you slapped him what he was
big that's hardcore man I haven't
figured out the timing yet
I just mash it ok you can't be ping
camping you're not be purple look at my
shorts yes
do you see my shorts my pants agree whoa
whoa what what is that thing around your
neck home to cry oh that's a really
that's really big zipper you got there
is that it's that for the fan fictions
yes so I don't understand what I didn't
work you I'm fairly certain I click the
button back
how fast I kept [ __ ] up to click do
you want this
I keep getting achievement for not doing
anything oh Jesus health and once that
fills up you press hit twice and then he
can use your special power ah that's my
new tactic it didn't work
just sit look order yeah I'm just gonna
be real I'm having fun here
what what happened that's Oh our is
pretty cool actually I can go through
walls interesting what he's son Danny
man monorails dancing dancing there's
some people missing about this game it's
called being MLG oh god oh you got me
you can job ow
to trot you tried so Assad to be a Candy
Man
oh god it's lagging Oh for you to yeah
it'll like for all of us at the same
time it's a that's how that's all right
that's future yeah I used to be back in
the game back in the game back in the
day yeah what are you doing through my
body game is game it's cold since I'm
the one who's play this game before we
got a have it out on you cap okay let's
go
how can read you got right team blue eye
we're here so that beanie cry or is it
that your hair I don't understand
ah that's a beanie you have to change
somewhat oh yeah it's Super Smash
Brothers inspiring our I just realized
yeah it is I like it sweet me too
okay let's play ball with crime you
can't do it wrong neighborhood
[ __ ] are the right actually he
prolly yeah oh god no I click I swear to
God I hit jump lie like there's this lag
going on in this game on him oh I [ __ ]
him up ah ah [ __ ] hip okay I don't even
get in time to like Indian hi it's Mike
Andy nice one we're hip for the kids
you're like not be whoa nice alligator
like linking I believe okay that's and
you
that I didn't know but wait my ball so
the ball changes colors depend on who
can get hit right yeah yeah here wait
you can't get hit by your own color nope
no is it always like that
yeah why do you want Funimation so you
can your own ball can hurt you too but
if we do that before [ __ ] crazy
what's up God so how do you like it not
let it hit you by hitting it or it back
when it comes to you okay but I thought
they died you had two numbered or some
shader I don't know are you not
I'm say yes yes I am mentally challenged
thank you for finally realizing man like
it takes a while for some people to take
notice but you guys have lasted the
longest no that works I yes
why do you do that little climb is that
your signature that's this this thing he
can do that
Oh what you can do it oh [ __ ] am I
supposed to do in life
give me just appreciate how I walk come
on pass it pass the ball you're [ __ ]
that guy that's a ball hug I am I'm
never good at this PJ I think it's
probably cuz you guys have hats and I
don't have a hat oh god you're dead whoa
you're not dead
oh yeah you're dead the bar you're not
dead watering the actual sledge oh my
god Ken come on did you do it Wow we
guys can get stalled but you play too
do you play this game quite a bit so
don't try to be a snitch I how's this
it's rhymes its rhymes it right and it's
just all Grimes it rhymes
let me have a and lies it that's fair
enough
yeah do you want to try the mode um out
where the mode you can even get you by
your own ball yes
no I'll just die more no thanks okay
well don't make it too spicy I'm not
even gonna tell you it so you didn't
even tell me that I can't get hit by my
own ball awesome written president
wasn't at all happy
they're just get ready I am ready
my body's right and not I'm not just
saying that like my I've been through
some [ __ ] to get to this point
hi damn is that what Eminem says
probably man I'll represent its kind of
sitting at a pool here and just this
crappy looking pool with C wood in it I
think it looks pretty good you just need
some more work and it's not wood it's I
am Iren obviously I would like some kind
of metal copper is it I think we might
have to restart the game and I think we
should just appreciate art I look at my
butt right you're right I am like I lose
game oh they crash for me and now
everyone sees my skype in case I don't
forget threaded travel yeah I can
probably only do a couple more because
the lady friend is waiting oh dude tell
her I said hello I read now wait no way
I'm not ready I want to be the Blackie
there we go Mickey Mouse that [ __ ]
looks so cool all the kids are gonna be
out how did you get that hey look at all
that fruit punch water down there Oh
looks delicious
I don't like myself that much what I'm a
piece of [ __ ] what oh talking about all
this self-loathing Skinner I meant like
with my outfit oh oh okay I guess I can
love this I love this game it's really
cool I kind of like paint but good
that's how it looks like to me
who's a heavy face ah haha yes [ __ ] see
really how did it even fly it like
gravity should affect it at some point
wait where's Newton in this game it's
not really bout it's like all right have
you ever seen flubber yes I [ __ ] love
a same concept it's plumberry you sling
him in the middle Zord
okay that's not that oh can let me win
come on whenever we want I mean it's man
thanks for that thanks for that thanks
for that I'm out there's been great
can't even win one game huh this game is
fun I would love to play more actually
it's cool it's pretty good